but what I think people are really
offended by it is this notion that we
have to join in in not seeing reality
and not seeing reality I'm a woman now
you know I'm black careful fund obscure
this is then we're back so glad to have
this next guest on with us we've had him
on before but we haven't had him on via
Skype so you can go to lot with credit
calm if you're listening to rest early
to see his cute little poem author of
werewolf clop Andrew Clavin thanks for
being on sir it's a pleasure sort of
yeah let's do away with the with the
pleasantries here social niceties as it
were they are not require it's miserable
having to be on Detroit so it's very
exciting
yeah closer than any of us want to be to
Detroit
hey I love Detroit no yes great
restaurants great museums all kinds of
cool stuff
if you survive there's a lot of fun
things to do while you're there but what
what kind of restaurants do they have
like American Coney Island Lafayette
Coney Island the Hard Rock Cafe is a
killer restaurant slows confront
abundance on legendary funda people want
to hear what andrew has to say Andrew
you need to come to Detroit and have
some really fun time at all these great
restaurants I'm on it fun on my way
there there are very few of you around
so I'm so glad that we have so Andrew
okay we made it's one of those things
you have so much that you've done it's I
kind of I've talked about this before
like when I met Clint Eastwood the one
time and then we talked about this
dropper yeah well no it's it's because
don't worry I end up looking
I can ask I didn't know what to say you
know I met him an attorney said you know
I'm I'm Clint he actually said his name
and I remember going I mean what do you
say I loved you in every which way but
loose you know like what do you go ahead
Clint Howard I loved you Clavin you've
done so much that it's tough to just
sort of pick a topic so I mean you write
a lot of fiction so let's talk about
that because there aren't many
conservatives I guess out there or who
are as outspokenly conservative more so
in the creative realm you know in
writing fiction why do you think it's so
dominated by leftists well the couple of
reasons one day blacklist us I mean in
Hollywood it's just true you know that
you can you can lose work like that for
being an outspoken left winger I mean
people who have come out to people who
simply came out and would not back Obama
which is not even as far to the Levin
you can be pretty middle-of-the-road
yeah you know they lost work and if
you're not John Boyd if you're not Clint
Eastwood you know you are going to pay a
price so that means that people keep
their heads down and that's a little
less true in the fiction world but it's
still true in the fiction world I mean
the publishing industry is is completely
dominated by New York left-wing
sensibilities and it's not that it's not
that they're evil it's that they just
see the world that so much that way that
they assume that you must be evil for
disagreement do you get a little bit of
a Jew path no how bad is that that means
everybody hates you and and secondly no
it's really you know I will tell you a
story talking to one of the smartest
people in publishing I know where my
favorite women in publishing I once said
to her look I think I can promote this
book by getting on Sean Hannity and she
said who's that oh gosh no it's one
thing it's one thing to say I never
watch Hannity is one thing to say you
know I like Hannah but who's that really
you know I mean they usually you hear
that for Crowder thanks rubble that
Robert not even
some kind of a pond scum that hasn't
been identified Thanks you're such a
great backup so so Andrew you're right
you kind of touch on that I remember I
was in a meeting and people will say
it's not true and I generally think
people have greater victim complexes and
exist in reality I'll acknowledge that
absolutely but I do think this is one of
those cases I mean I remember I was
right there I mean I've been with major
agencies you name the top three eight
top five agencies I've been with two of
them and remember being in a meeting one
more before you're screwed or being in a
meeting and they were talking about in
Obama fundraiser that's it's funny that
you mentioned that and someone said yeah
you know just thing going on if you want
we can show you around and introduce you
to the rest of the team and my manager
was there so you know you have a manager
in an agent because you need a bunch of
redundancies in the entertainment
industry and my manager goes no he's
more likely to be at the pail and
fundraiser and I'm not even a Palin fan
and they just went who and we're sitting
there going I mean everyone there might
have been 16 people in that room you
know these meetings right the glorified
Michael Keaton sort of Batman table and
not a single person thought oh wait hold
on a second maybe he doesn't agree with
us it was just that's the starting off
point you know as a screenwriter you
walk into a room to sell material and
the way these meetings all work is you
have a small talk you start off with
small talk and during the Bush years the
small talk would be literally sits you
know you come in with your material to
sell your script or your idea your pitch
and the they would start off like is
that Bush an idiot or what right and
because I'm a loudmouth I would say well
actually I sort of support him and it
was like hey don't let the door hit you
on your way out I mean you're not
selling that script in that room and
it's just it is very it's not a
blacklist it's a grey list I mean let's
put it that way very few people will
literally throw you out of the room but
it it makes a difference it's just no
question about it yeah a great list has
got to be tough on you because you don't
son well you get kind of a sh
you know I thought what you were going
to say is that I can't keep my mouth
shut and that's a KO unfortunately
unfortunately closer to the truth a lot
of guys have perfected this thing where
you know somebody will say is it's Obama
great or what and I'll just go like yeah
hurry up really hard to do that where
you where you shut up about something
that bothers you that much right where
you let people assume that you have
principles that you don't ask well if it
were easier to do that we'd all be
leftists louder with Crowder we'll be
right back with Andrew Clavin we are
back with Andrew Clavin author of
werewolf cop and so much else follow him
on twitter at Andrew Clavin Andrew so I
wanted to talk with you about this we
were just talking about this when I was
filling in for Dana's show have you seen
the complaints about spider-man and
Stanley's response no oh you haven't
seen this not her this okay I'm sorry I
don't mean to send your career room like
I can't play banter Clavin wasn't in a
no they complained that you know they
picked the new spider-man and I think
he's a new he's an English white guy
right Jared yeah yeah it was just like
the last one just like the last one kind
of it I liked the last one a lot I
thought he did a great job
both of the last two films with the
whole Gwen story arc I thought were
really good
I actually yes babies not mourn about
now no I like them except for I thought
the Jamie Foxx character was a little
weird
I was yeah he was kind of annoying the
story every two years maintain the same
spider-man or just every two years night
I did hear that the new one is not going
to have the origin story they're gonna
dive right in with them already being
set which is good because I would have
just shot myself about the same origin
story again well then we've changed it a
little bit now the spider walks up his
left arm instead of his right well now
they're actually gonna jump right in
Clavin I don't know if you heard they're
jumping right in at the moment Peter
Parker wins an espy for Lorena Bobbitt
his penis
that's how the Marley's were dead to
begin at us I'm hoping so the legitimate
complaint was that he's spider-man is
white and he's straight and I guess
there are different sort of parallel
universes where spider-man is Latino or
he's biracial or it's insane that he's
gay so they're mad about this creature
and exactly I mean I just feel I feel
like I'm this yeah well arachnid
Americans right an arachnid Americans
you're absolutely right with the point
that comes with this is Stanley's
response which was fantastic and I think
he's just sort of gotten to that age
where isn't care anymore because he just
said listen you wouldn't make the black
panther Swiss said okay I don't see why
you have to change something that
already exists they are what they are he
said how about creating new characters
and then he ended it with hell I'll do
it myself
it's gone down to the point where I
don't know if you see this in Hollywood
I definitely see it everywhere else in
the United States where we've run out of
white guilt and I think it's like you
know it started at an all-time high you
know and you had like Remember the
Titans and everyone's thinking great
this is a great film we need this and
obviously you know everyone should be
allowed to play football on the same
team and these race riots are terrible
and now we've you know now that you know
slavery has been abolished everyone has
the right to vote people that you have a
black president they're down to not only
comic books but that he's straight yeah
I know this is like when Chris Rock
complained he said that he said black
people you know aren't aren't wealthy
they're they're rich Oprah's rich but
she's not wealthy like Bill Gates and I
thought if that's what you're
complaining about
stop googling is that you're not Bill
Gates
stop complaining because you're doing
fine Gates is probably complaining that
he's not the head of Apple that's right
so yeah I mean I think I think the the
narrative string on this story has just
run out you know somewhere at the end of
it at the end of a string of this story
there's some transgender cat just
playing every 4th guy Muhammad is
chasing somebody around with a scimitar
trying to cut his head off but that that
tells us that tells us nothing about the
religion of Islam right that we can't we
can't make any generalization about
Islam from that fact but one psychopath
one crazy racist psychopath
shoots people in Trustin and that tells
us everything you need to know about
America and not saying you know they say
every devil Muslim kill somebody here
well most Muslims are peaceful one
psychopath white psychopaths kill some
black people and suddenly I'm a bad guy
I just think it's playing out yeah well
I think I think it's better again that's
where you pull out your Jew pass of
course you're a Christian got Jewish in
me yeah well no one likes the Irish fun
dip that's just about this conversation
took a weird turn I don't know no I
think you're right Clavin and I think
it's it's gotten to a point and I'm
seeing a turn culturally with younger
people but not fiscally socialism is
fine but culturally they're going gosh I
mean we're limiting ourselves and our
ability simply to speak on anything and
I feel like this is sort of emblematic
of the left with the spider-man issue
you know instead of creating new
characters they want to complain about
one and hijack it and I think political
correctness you can correct me if I'm
wrong because you're the expert here
with fiction I think political
correctness has a really sort of
kneecapped creativity to the point that
leftists are for the first time having a
hard time creating new stories am I
wrong I mean you know this werewolf got
not to not to plug the book too much but
when I brought it out it has a character
in it a main character who is full
ethically incorrect who was always
pointing out that this one only got her
job because is latina and women
shouldn't be doing this he said he's a
terrible sexist you know he's not the
hero but he has this loudmouth
everything he says is you know it's just
that's enough truth in it where you
can't quite dismiss it you know so it's
very annoying to people who who are
politically correct that character alone
kept the book from selling overseas in
Europe in Europe that the fact that that
character existed was just an absolute
he's done you know a son-in-law named
meathead that bad you know I mean he's
just like a little over the edge and and
so and that's coming here - I mean that
is gonna start coming here - if we don't
stop it the only difference here is as
long as we got the First Amendment until
John Roberts decides it doesn't mean
what it says it means as long as we've
got the First Amendment you know I think
we can always they can always be
somebody will create a new publishing
house a new movie company that makes the
movies that no one else will make and
overrides those protests and and if you
do that I think you win because people
are hungry for it they're hungry for we
when you hear look when you hear Jerry
Seinfeld Chris Rock say they won't play
college campuses anymore because in
rocks phrase they're too conservative
what he meant was there two leftists and
they won't let them get past the george
carlin said this the daddy of them all
said he wouldn't play college campuses
you know that it's gone in a very very
weird direction I mean look we
conservatives have said all along that
left this is fascism with a human face
but they didn't listen and now they're
finding out I think it's a good point
and I mean what you also raises the
point that I think a lot of people miss
and I've talked about this with sargon
of akkad and Miley innopolis over there
in the UK it was also super gay ya know
he loves even always has to point it out
big fan of the Wiener that Milo what I
think is Chris Rock doesn't realize he's
now facing the monster that he has
absolutely created that's right that's
right that none of them wants to none of
the most aggressive that metal
nobody wants to say like oh wait this is
us this is us censoring us because guys
like us we don't care obviously I mean
we wouldn't be talking to each other
right if we gave a rat's you know I mean
I always I always wondered I was
wondering why the feminists don't come
after me more and I said they realize
they know you know what they gonna do to
me right let me hold the door for you on
your way out I think that's the thing
you know the only people that can be
censored here now other people who care
whether you like them or not
it's a good point I do think feminists
might have some they can do is get
they're trying to get to your wife and
have her take half that's what they're
trying to do now it's like it's a tough
sell like I was talking with my wife and
we've talked about this I've talked
about sexism a lot on this program and I
said yes I am sexist in a sense that I
will never hit my wife no I treat her
better than I treat any man and it's
because she's a woman I mean it's just
sexism it's just on the positive side
you know they want to be these cafeteria
sexist
you know feminists where they take they
pick and they choose what they want and
I talk about it all and it's a tough
sell for a feminist who's you know who's
unsure so unattractive that she has
convinced herself a compliment is some
kind of a microaggression
to tell your beautiful wife or my
beautiful wife that they should be
ashamed to be with men who treat them
like princesses ashamed to be with me
yes you're married son what is wrong
with you
no Clayman I mean listen and you're
right in there you're right in the belly
of the beast as you do this you were
talking with the Muslim think have you
seen the polls that recently just came
out on American Muslims what 25 percent
it's okay to kill Americans as long as
but only as long as it's in favor of
jihad right
not just randomly oh yeah yeah all right
like it's not okay to kill them like
because you caught him on To Catch a
Predator or something trial
oh there it's part of the jihad we drew
a picture of Moe Mohammed also fifty
percent on that poll were in favor of
Sharia law one fifty-one percent and you
know I think it's very important every
time we mention Sharia law to say that
it's an atrocity in and of itself during
the Western system of law is something
you know those remember those old
pictures of like the eight evolving into
the human being I mean the Western
system of law is at the very pinnacle of
that process it's something that like
you have to be you have to come out of
the swamps to get to that place and to
hand that over in any area as they
sometimes do in France and in England to
Sharia which is savage law is despicable
you are going to get letters my friend
I'm comparing Muslims to Strela focuses
on this subhuman chart here's people's
address is it Australopithecus Bo's I
yeah but it doesn't matter that's okay
you know what we're gonna end this for
the radio side and keep you for the web
exclusive Andrew Klavan follow him on
Twitter at Andrew claim and werewolf
caught fantastic book if you were
listening to rest really go to ladder
with Crider calm for an extended uncut
interview where he's incredibly profane
and anti-semitic we're off into
uncharted territory back with Andrew
Clavin and you're off the air now sir so
you don't need to worry about the FCC
okay so this yeah I think what happened
is Barack Obama said you know he said
your and then binds it that's a big deal
you know like it's one of those things I
was sitting there talking you know I
mean Andrew we talked about I'm not
really like a particularly profane guy I
think that cussing tends to be a tool of
lazy inherent
hey that's why I use it well I mean
there's there lovingly you know there
are plenty of other indicators as to
your laziness funding without your mouth
but I do I so I don't use it a lot
where's my dad like he cusses so
brilliantly it was used to punctuate a
sentence where I'm going I mean that's
where language is a craft you know but
does it use the the is the French words
the French cusses like your mom you were
talking about how they cuss with things
like Eucharist yes yes chalice
tabernacle these are the worst I've
talked about this Andrew haven't we
those are the worst cuss words in French
no stupid it's malaria
well like in french-canadian because you
know it's the state denomination as
Catholicism so you know I guess sort of
blasted me against the church is
considered like using the Lord's name in
vain so the worst was that about Mack
Tabernacle or so like if you curse yes
yes and you added at the end of a phrase
so it'll be like you'd say like us I'm a
schmuck that bout Mack that's the e like
you punctuate it and so then you have
the influence on English Canadians and
Jerez gonna have the sense of outrage
because my audience will be offended
like give us a language warning it's
true though where you'll you'll have
english-speaking Canadians who will
punctuate their sins with a cuss words
they'll be like ah the stupid soundboard
is broken and you're laughing but
Canadians don't even realize how silly
it sounds well why don't why don't they
say the stupid sound words broken
tabernac I guess they have some level
pride what they're trying they're
bridging the multiculturalist gap talk
about what oh the Islamic thing yeah the
Sharia law is a gross abomination of
anyone who if they want to be consistent
and caring about human rights to me
that's one of the great sort of
dichotomies at the left where I'm going
well I mean you hate Americans because
they think that giving Bruce Caitlyn
Jenner and SP is kind of silly I mean
that's the level of my hate I'm like
well Caitlyn Jenner technically hasn't
won anything and that is enrages them
but stoning a woman because she was
raped
hey yeah it's a cultural thing that's
right see I think what people are
offended by now well at least what I am
offended by what I think most of the
Conservatives I know it's not nobody
cares what Bruce Jenner does with his
body parts he can fling them out the car
with those he drives not mainstream as
far as I'm concerned candy canes in a
sentence exactly you know but what I
think people are really offended by is
this notion that we have to join in in
not seeing reality in not seeing reality
I'm a woman now you know I'm black
careful fun disguises is then my my
theory on the whole process is just
accept people no matter how different
they are as long as they're not cutting
people's heads off and you know blowing
buildings up well I almost say - mock
people relentlessly yeah no exactly I
mean my whole thing is what we would not
see this is what happens we've gotten
off on another tangent and funding it oh
my gosh this is louder with Crowder and
off on a tangent I know my issue is this
Andrew and I talked with it's funded
about this people if it is I mean it is
classified technically as a psychiatric
disorder medically in my morbid obesity
that's not classified as psychiatric
that's classified as physical no but I
mean something in here is causing it
prolactin Oh lack of herself respect I
don't know self restraint I don't know
well my point is this people who suffer
from any kind of condition let's call it
depression and social anxiety through
any of those or generally the last
people to recognize it now when we tell
those people hey listen you suffer from
depression let us help you
recognizing it and saying let's help you
with steps a B and C is not hateful and
the people who say hey you know what I
think like my Lilly innopolis I think
this might be better treated through
therapy and through counseling then it's
surgical procedure that comes with so
many complications you know John Hopkins
won't perform my therapist said I give
up and said don't bother we're funded by
Megan I make an actual point you're my
point is that I'm not any more hateful
than just saying okay you're a woman and
so my problem is applying intent to
someone saying well you know what the
science is out most of the science is in
and you can't change your sex it's not
hateful over someone say hey but let's
try and help you with this let's let me
try and help you accept who you were
born to be as opposed to just saying
well let's let's accept all of it and
you're told that one is hateful and one
is loving and that's the narrative and
that's what bothers me
well that's the only way when you have a
narrative that is essentially false or
not everything to let says is false but
a lot of what they say you have a
narrative is essentially post the only
way to sell it is by keeping the guy
who's saying the Emperor isn't wearing
any clothes from say hanging the
Emperor's and wearing any clothes and
the only way to do that is to say oh
that's a hateful thing to say to say
that the Emperor is naked you know just
because he happens not to have a stitch
of clothing on that that's hateful
that's people and if you can intimidate
people into saying that then the emperor
is dressed you know identify as a
dressed person the emperor said you know
I never get it from that perspective you
using a fable to connect it is helpful
well that's how you become a fiction
writer and throw your life away like
that so and that's a fun dip cards come
crumbling down that's a fun that looks
at himself in the mirror completely
naked and says I'm clothed I'm not
wearing anything right now
that's amazing ink work a fun dip yeah
yeah that's a hell of a tattoo of
spider-man on my chest this is true of
gay biracial Latino spider-man that's
the new rule and this is something
Andrew I think there's a lot of headway
to be made with people who aren't
inherently conservative there is a
rebound effect I think with the free
speech issue and that's why I'm always
interested to see as someone who works
in writing specifically which is to me I
mean it's the pinnacle of free speech in
stand-up comedy I think you know it's
it's at the forefront of that but what
about reading the weather on the radio
boundaries there's no question about the
comedy is where people say things that
that are purposely out there and you
know are kind of the thing comedies
exists or than that part of the brain
that is thinking what you're not
supposed to be thinking you know and
which we all have and you bring that out
and it's funny you know and that's funny
but if you get stoned for it it loses a
little bit get stoned first and then you
know the comic that is better then it's
hilarious Sean what's your example Tommy
Chong used to be so funny until it
became such an activist for pot it was
like no it's like it's funny when you're
doing it and an old you know an old
Chevy and you're joking about it and the
people watching in our stone but once
you start like pushing for legislation
that's not fun anymore legislation isn't
fun you know since we're going off on
tangents actually brings us back to the
question of language of four-letter
words like Tabernacle Jerry Seinfeld
said this I open my Tribune with wrong
person he said if you curse and people
laugh you might be funny but if you
don't curse some people laugh you
actually you know you're funny and and I
I've seen this a million times when you
talk about saying the thing that it's
just out there that you're not supposed
to say the easiest thing to say is a
four-letter word and then people laugh
and they giggle because you've exposed
that thing a harder thing to do is to
bring out that idea that you're not
supposed to be thinking that politically
incorrect or you know socially incorrect
idea and bring that out and expose
people for they kind of broken sinners
they think they are and that's and
that's and that's very funny and I think
you know it's interesting i watch louis
c.k is fascinating to me that the guy to
me he's fifty fifty fifty percent of his
material that's virtually clean is
hilarious the minute he gets off on sex
it's not it's not that I don't think it
can be funny but I still think he is
well you know it's funny you say that
because we were actually gonna have Jim
Norton on who's a just a great guy
overall in these I mean as filthy as
comedy gets but he also doesn't use the
f-word as a crutch condom and that
wasn't this I mean Jerry Seinfeld is a
great example a clean comic but you have
HuffPo writers rebutting him and
protesting I mean he's
you know not protesting Marc Maron
they're not protesting louis c.k are
these filthy comics they're protesting
jerry seinfeld just like i was banned
from college multicultural affairs I
mean at this point I didn't even say ass
in my act it was as clean as humanly
possible the miniskirt was just a
miniskirt people uncomfortable Draya was
the next Eddie Izzard exactly but the
issue so Jim Norton is actually a great
example he's dirty but he doesn't use
doesn't use cussing as a crutch and I
say that because you see the same thing
with hip hop and I say this is a great
fan of hip hop but hip hop is very much
you're using language as an instrument
okay and so you need to man it's also
mathematical and that okay here's this
verse this verse needs to match it needs
to match in some kind of a sequence with
syllables right so I need eight
syllables well gosh I need to fill in
one F word and you fill in A to F a or F
for 94 mother-effer that's what happens
so it's a lot easier to go like man I
don't have none of these verses work
Grammy's noise a lot of real evil say it
comes to be lazy songwriting of course
it is I mean that's you know you can
tell the difference I mean David Mamet
who was famous for using the F word like
and continues just building something he
does it with this beautiful poetry and
when he's on his game it is really funny
and intense you know and it's just like
he's talking about the way men talk you
know and that's and that's great you
know but if you're right if you throw it
in it just loses everything
I love how with David Mamet everyone
just thought he was sort of subversive
and I thought he was cutting-edge until
he came out as a conservative and then
everything he'd ever done was actually
sexist it was terrible
you know I mean it's funny the funny
thing is I mean he was he was an
anti-feminist from the start I think
that was his way in was that's what kind
of opened his eyes to it I mean he says
it was like Jewish stuff and all this
but if you go back this place his
depictions of women even I was written
in Iran
Sariah I'm gonna show up somewhere here
have you ever seen that movie yeah so I
don't want it it's not a pleasant watch
it's a it's like a musical
you know that's guys I'm waiting for the
musical to come out in
it's Cyrus the guy made the film is a
good friend of mine and it's a beautiful
movie and it really is but right after
it came out I was sitting in a bar and I
looked over and there he was sitting
next to me kind of staring into his
drink and I said I said let me guess
people don't want to go out on doing
dates you know so whenever you write a
movie you have to sort of think to
yourself hey honey want to go see a
movie about a woman being stoned right
yeah I used to manage a movie theater
and when we were showing The Passion of
the Christ I never saw date couples
coming in for it was always large like
church groups organized coming in and my
des fleurs I've never seen so much
Kleenex well not because you've never
been in a theater where people Herman
was I do have an issue with that they
ignore the happy ending yeah except he
did it so it's funny the first thing I
said I mean I saw it alone I'm sitting
in a packed theater I said sitting next
to a stranger that resurrections he is
so quick I actually turned to the guy
when the lights came up and I said you
know the book had a happy ending
I put the ranch cheddar powder in my
popcorn I missed it no he's not will you
bring up the popcorn Stephen and I tell
you another thing about The Passion of
the Christ that was the lowest sales for
snacks out of any movie I ever showed
there was it really nobody was buying
snacks was going I got to get me a big
bag of popcorn and a box of goobers to
go in and watch that they went in they
didn't buy soda they didn't buy anything
whether they didn't make the sequel yeah
and the sequel is just the happy part
and I don't think I was gettin wants to
do that I mean I do could always come
back with revelations that would make a
hell of a movie you know if anybody else
any other subject had made that kind of
money
there'd be a sequel every every money
talk about remaking spider-man if
anything but a Christian movie had made
that kind of profit because 25 million
dollars use made like a billion or
something at this point any any other
subject it would be like how can we make
Jesus - yeah exactly this time Chris
Hemsworth is Christ Chris tell us about
your workout routine for this did a lot
of carpentry and then I tried to learn
an American accent where I just
exaggerated my words and I suck at it no
I actually watched John Barrowman yeah
respect expect font of me to be helping
fund up with that closet door any day
now it bothers me and I talk everybody's
got one on a list right I have no idea
he's talking about Hugh Jackman I know
my issue is this and a lot of people I
mean you work out you work on set with
enough actors and I have to the steroid
thing is so rampant and nobody wants to
talk about it and I go okay well let me
let me give you an idea what did you
really think that this guy put it did
steroids okay Christian Bale couldn't do
one pushup
when he went from the machinist to the
Dark Knight and then 220 and lean as
someone who's trained my entire life who
walks when at two and a quarter who has
a fifty four-year-old father who was in
the top
single-digit percentile of people in his
age bracket for strength I know what it
takes now let me give you kind of the
timeline most people who are in
Hollywood were drama geeks they were
theater nerds right and they decided
they wanted to go to Hollywood and make
it as creative types only now
have to turn the drama geek into
Superman so that requires a lot of
chemical enhancement these aren't you
know you have some exceptions but these
tend to not be you know the absolute
best of the best athletes who are
playing superheroes it's a stretch and
when you see someone go oh look you know
I just started you right and I've put on
30 pounds of muscle in three months
you're telling me that Chris had warts
testicles are the size of he's walking
around with Simon birch balls that's
what I'm saying necessarily him but yeah
I mean even him if you look at him like
it eyes top weight you know he weighed
about 210 that's not that big and it's
just it's just again it's it's the whole
sort of house of cards that is the
entertainment industry and I saw like
the Dwayne the rock Johnson yes I
remember laughing so hard were they
asked him point-blank about steroids and
but he actually is an athlete but he
goes well not an actor he goes I tried
them once in college and they weren't
for me try the woods alright yeah
everyone goes through a second puberty
when they're 44 Wow he wasn't even that
big in his pro wrestling days you know I
mean like all of a sudden he's
40-something and he puts on another 20
pounds of muscle I mean you know you
know how the human body ages sorry we
got off on a tangent that's kind of what
happens but but my point is just it's a
fake industry and then these people come
out and they want us to adopt their
political views I guess it's supposed to
be a fake industry that's fine that's
good you know we want them to be
better-looking than us the women are
more beautiful than men or you don't get
it that's those are the stories we want
to go see but why are we listening to
them when they start talking about
reality I mean quite you know you just
say thank you like fold up his notebook
you know right just you just keep
talking bin and I'll be back you know
and you started telling me about you
know Batman keeps peeking mr. Renner I
got some stuff in Uganda I have to cover
you'll get somebody that is aware and is
intelligent that's an actor that does
something
really good with their life and then
they serve two terms and then followed
by a bush and the actors are artists
listen I admire actors they are amazing
they what they do is amazing and and you
almost never see a bad performance in an
American movie I don't know how much of
that happens in the editing room but it
is an amazing thing that our movie
actors are not gonna Will Ferrell film
they all suck for my money no one does a
better Hamlet just hates him because
he's part of that frat pack and he gets
compared to Chris Farley a lot and it
brings up bad memories all of these guys
are annoying
oh come on fun dip seriously you need to
be so bitter if I'm not bitter who's
gonna do it somebody has to be the
bitter guy your wife let her do it
she's married to you well like that
would make anybody bitter but she's just
like all sweet all the time that's a
serious problem and she's got a
character flaw so you can sure I'm
trying to think of how we can write this
[ __ ] I don't think there's a way to it's
sinking it's sinking the nation or the
show that's the question you know I
guess I don't know I mean I'm turning to
Andrew clay let me ask you this so can
we talk about this and I joke about it a
lot but you're you know born Jewish and
you're a Christian you're a con happen
how much crap do you get for that
because they don't lose a lot of team
players no they don't lose a lot of team
players you know it's it's funny I get a
certain amount of it in fact somebody on
my website called me a blithering idiot
just the other day I wanted to say like
I almost never blew their what are you
you know I get it on my on my blog at
teaching media when I make Christian
points I was very moved by the
Charleston the family of the Charleston
victims coming out and forgiving the
killer and I was talking about what a
beautiful moment that was
moment that reminds us of what the whole
thing is supposed to be about you know
that it actually is a different way of
looking at the world in a way that was
no one ever saw the world like that
before Christ and I was talking about
the beauty of that and that a couple of
people showed up and said you know like
you stupid x2 you know if you if you
knew what's and that's actually very
kind just like stupid ex Jew considering
I'm not Jewish in any way shape or form
and I get called the Jew [ __ ] every day
you know what you know the second map
yeah you know with the anti-semite seem
to congregate and what you can explain
this to me you - yeah I do a lot of
YouTube videos I did those clicking on
the cultural and revolting truth and you
go down the line and like there's always
three this is hilarious this is great
I've never been able to figure out
anti-semitism anyway ever every Jewish
person I've ever met
aside from one guy who used to do a
radio show that I had to produce has
been super super nice but I don't
understand why why has the world hated
this one particular group versus they
they brought God the world is pretty
annoying I really do believe that the
underlying hatred even though among
Christian even that Christian
anti-semitism is is the underlying age
which is pretty rare to be fair
Christian anti-semitism airs I'll give
you that thing I love about Americans
Americans are not American Christians
are not anti-semitic so they're always
like how come how come you guys are
angry at us you know a thousand years
before you yeah I mean listen I like you
guys like you're good people but could
you stop being so damn jewy all
time like this I like that you just just
not so Joey not so much looking women
too though especially in Israel oh my
god even named for them and I can't
remember it so it's a fruit that's
prickly on the outside but soft on the
inside and that's what they're supposed
to represent Jewish women and I have to
say they are something else
I I do not appreciate your potty mouth
come on with your you know your
euphemism if your fruit and your insides
I've read songs of Solomon sir I tell
you what that's a real statement because
you've got fun dip on a screen in front
of you if you can get hot and flustered
while I'm on the visual he has found his
happy place all right Andrew we could
have you on forever but the fact is we
need to have you back on and so please
before we say something that we're going
to regret I think we've kind of hit that
point okay so where can people best find
you werewolf cop obviously read it by us
please go on as you said Andrew Clavin
is my twitter feed and you can also go
on and reclaim comm and see all my watch
formats is it available in hardcover
softcover kindle audiobook what do you
got hardcover Kindle and audiobook the
next audiobook you should have me do it
Oh can't be beaten there you know we're
gonna end this on a positive note no
never
and then you just do I'm sorry Andrew I
just hey I'm a [ __ ] I admit it I can't
make it up to you I tell you what
hold your anti-semitic comments for only
the Jewish half of Andrew Clavin and
hold all your anti-fat comments for
Stevens ass I know this is a terrible
sign-off fun dip
stop it Andrew Klavan on
werewolf cop go buy it and we'll have
him back someday once he can clean
himself from the stem fun dip do not say
anything Lodwick Ryder stop it stop it
stop a sabot laterals crowd I almost
said fund it in oh my god you're ruining
my life flatter with credit we'll be
right back hey if you like this
interview with Andrew Clavin there's
something wrong with you but you might
enjoy these interviews with other guests
or I don't know what's playing maybe
it's a short web video those are more
easily digestible they're two minutes
you don't need to think too much I do
those too